[Applause]
so yeah so I'm PI mc3 contributor
blogger data scientists consumer alcohol
um you can find him Twitter with spring
coil and I'm not pitching this but it's
something I've done which is I've put
together a collection a course on
probabilistic programming so if you're
interested you can have a look so I go
to talk about I don't hear me yeah I
assume so so I'm going to talk by modern
Bayesian workflow this can't be some
like the last two years of doing this
stuff professionally using this library
lock but also like recent research so
one of the questions that you get asked
whenever you do something niche in
machine learning world is why would you
do it why not just logistic regression
so my defence of probabilistic
programming or Bayesian statistics which
I use as synonyms is that Laurie have
lots of problems are small data problems
you know like in Airlines for instance
or insurance or finance or sports sports
is a good example or heterogeneous data
problems so like in pharmaceuticals or
maybe even agriculture so traditional ML
models I'm not gonna quite say XG boost
sucks but the organs because I would be
controversial but actually Bruce doesn't
solve all problems and these kinda like
traditional like best-in-class ml models
don't incorporate domain expertise and
they don't work well of a small data so
anecdotally whenever I was researching
for this court class class this talk and
someone presents an example where he did
Bayesian model and I got 0.75 a you see
I did a XG Bruce model on the same data
and got 0.6 so I was particular like
pharmaceutical use case and I had a lot
of categorical data but it shows you
that like you know you know don't just
use one hammer so my kind of like goal
is just talk to you about our new set of
tools now the other reason this is very
important is GDP arc happened that
anyone get involved for doing GDP our
project
does anyone want a drink or like current
slang or some sort of likes you know
like we should have a meet-up just like
that and but if you work with health
care data if you work with insurance
data you know finance data you're you're
gonna be working in a regulated
environment we're gonna see intact more
regulation you know largely because of
everything that's happened and but you
know but we're also gonna say that a
need for more interpretability
so one of the defenses of these models
is they're incapable you get uncertainty
you can understand how your model you
were so we're going to discuss how to
debug Bayesian models we're gonna use
like you know you turn sound players
we're not going to talk about the
underlying engine too much and that's an
entire other course in itself this is PI
MC 3 specific but the same principles
apply to rania if anyone's not heard or
any Iranian zone by avi Briand the
talented scholar guy at stripe and Stan
bugs they all have very similar
ecosystems you know they have a slightly
different languages I prefer Phi M C 3
because I'm involved
I have no stake in the rest of them but
here the same principles apply so if you
want some exclusive notebooks I put
together a mailing list have a look
about that's gonna be when I what I'm
gonna show later on so one of the
reasons that's very interesting about
the history of Bayesian statistics so
the phase is quite an old technique
right days you'll died 100 150 plus
years ago I was only really when like
you know we had
okay sorry sorry okay I move too quick I
have a time limit yeah thank you okay
can I go now thanks lobby okay so - so
to handle things like large scales
problems or big data problems in a
Bayesian framework we need to use
Hamiltonian examples these are the
best-in-class samplers they are really
only about 10-15 years old and an
important thing that's very important
tonight Cernik an academic comp remark
is that they only work well under
certain conditions right and these
conditions are often swept under the
carpet so we often ignore why you know
in what cases these things these models
work you know we often say oh it's fine
you know
without following these certain
conditions your inference will be wrong
I mean decisions you make on the basis
of any analysis will be wrong so that's
kind of a very important thing sounds
very logical but I think you know in
industrial context we sometimes forget
that whether you like it or not your job
is to inform better decisions most data
scientists don't make decisions we
inform you might think your job is to
understand the truth or whatever but
that's bollocks all science you know
whether it's a time and besides the
science part of data science is about
making better decisions so if your
inference is wrong your and your
decisions will be wrong
so let's let's we're gonna quickly go
through Bayesian statistics so a random
variable is a function that converts
random events and here you have random
events two numbers that's all of this a
random variable has a probability
distribution
what specifies the probability that its
value falls in any given interval it
provides the probabilities of occurrence
of different possible outcomes in the
experiment in a discrete case which is
on the Left it's sufficient to specify a
probability mass function assigning a
probability to each possible outcome
it's not so easy in the continuous case
which is on the right the probability
density function describes in fortes no
probability and of any given value and
the probability that I come lies in a
given interval can be computed by
integrating the probability density
function over the interval it's very
important I've mentioned the word
integrating because as we remember from
from earlier calculus when we first
learnt calculus differentiation is a lot
easier than integration integration is
hard and we're going to learn why we had
to invent these algorithms so I suffered
through graduate school and I need
therapy for that and then you do things
like measure theory you do integrals and
expectations mappings algebra I looked
at this guy there is a really good
introduction by Mike Banner Court which
is here this is link Mike better cord is
a core developer to Stan and general
defender of the pursuit of like good
decisions and great guy and but he had a
has very thorough case studies very
thorough you know case studies and when
he talks were things in depth if you
like good academic writing about data
science it's as well worth reading so we
have more conventional distributions
they are map parameters and observations
to real numbers families of
distributions are parameterized by
different input so once a parameter set
me and as the standard deviation for
normal it becomes one distribution so so
that we can talk with distributions we
talk by random events for top of with
probability theory here's a very very
quick overview of Bayesian stats so the
key words here are likelihood right the
likelihood here is generally what you're
trying to figure out if 0 is your profit
is your prior distribution that's what
you put into your model that's you know
if you have domain expertise you'll put
that in you may for instance know that
your sales form like something like an
exponential distribution you may know
you know or you may know that Heights
and some kind of measurements that
you're looking at have a normal
distribution I'm the kind of important
thing here is that if you look at the
map you kind of run through the math
very quickly is that you have prior
proportional to likelihood times it's
like posteriors proportional to
likelihood times prior to get that you
need to do an integration and as I
already said integration is hard so why
is Bayesian inference hard because
integration is hard in the same way in
calculus it's harder than
differentiation and this is kind of like
the underlying challenge whenever you're
building models for this so we know so
the UM it is an entire class to do like
why MCMC samplers work and all the
source stuff well let's just take it as
a given the MCMC samplers allow us to
compute integrals we know theoretically
the MC MC will converge we call this an
asymptotic regime so we will get the
right answer however that assumes that
we have infinite time and infinite
computation you don't have infinite
computation even if you work for Google
or Amazon there's anyone here from
Google
tonight um even if you're even if you
find this or money is Jail and you do
not have you know em for the
computational time so we have no
guarantee that MCMC will converge you
know in practical computational time so
we need to diagnose our model we need to
like know if it converged or not we need
to know of our models wrongly specified
so there's a notebook and I got link
once you go down I'll have a look at our
through and take people through it um
but the workflow is roughly speaking
build the model your first model will
always be crap your 35th model will
always be corrupt your 97 model will
call it be corrupted um be diagnosed a
model by looking for divergences and
then you like your Reaper to me trace
the model and that's kind of like the
trick thing on the show the general folk
theorem of statistical computing which
comes from Andrew Gelman who's at
Columbia and a course town probably
invented stun actually is that if your
model takes a long time to fit your
model is pretty specified I won't have a
bottle that took a week to to converge
that was a waste of time and I should
have gone back to be specifying it and
not just leaving it and wasting
computational resources and contributing
to heat therefore the universe but you
that's kind of a thing that you have to
let go like balance
so everyone see that I'm not going to do
live coding because that's a bad idea
and I learned from experience you can
look in this notebook I talk a lot with
the math and the underlying reasons and
justification I'm not going to go
through this it's too late in the day
and um but we we we import our PI mc3
stuff and we're going to like talk about
like one very specific example a
specific example is called eight schools
example the eight screws example looks
at SAT scores SAT scores is a you know
as a standardized test for like high
school students in the US you have like
your mean score is 500 the highest
scoring get is 800 the lowest is 200 you
know their standard standard deviations
but each school had a treatment effect
and like they thought they had a
coaching method and their coaching
effect is like it's a treatment effect
so school a saw they got 28 points more
on the SATs from his coaching example
you know it's coaching um and you know
and you can see the other the other
scores you can see like that's quite
that's quite high compared to everything
else so you have eight schools you
there's that one of the questions is you
know what is your best estimate for the
effect of coaching on education
performance in these schools so you
consider this this estimated a fact
treatment effect is wrong and we're
trying to build a model to find a true
effect no one argument is that the best
estimate for for school a is 28 points
you can say it's an unbiased estimate
and standard error what else do you can
you hope for but on the other hand your
standard error which is 15 is larger
than estimated effect in most schools so
there's something wrong here
you can do a hypothesis test and this
feels to reject the hypothesis that the
true effect size is the same eight
points in all of the schools so an
auditor argument is that my best
estimate of the effect in school a is
eight points after all the same course
was taught in each of the schools so
each of these eight schools gives me a
single estimate of the CM quantity which
is the course effectiveness now neither
of these examples is actually
satisfactory one example we've you know
we've gone like we've can we've
regressed and mean too much we know that
schools are different and if you think
schools is a bit of a like an unusual
example well this could be any category
this could be riskiness of loans this
could be you know different kind of drug
types you know you know like the world
is very categorical in some sense so
rubin who invented this famous example
thought i think most people agree that
neither of these arguments represents
our state of knowledge the first
argument would treat school a completely
in isolation which you don't want to do
because you're giving up all your data
of your other seven schools
the second argument would assume that
the true effect in l schools is exactly
equal but we know there's variation in
life so ruin suggests a sort of middle
path assume that each school's true
effect is drawn from a normal
distribution with unknown mean and
standard deviation and to assume that
observe the fact in each school is
sampled from a normal distribution with
a mean equal to the true effect and
standard deviation given the table books
so it's a lot to absorb it's worth going
through these notebooks yourself you
will get this my advice is it took me a
long time to get my head around there's
eight schools it does take time one of
the problems of Bayesian statistics is
that in much the same way as deep
learning it is sophisticated a text
to learn however but when you get it
you'll start to see examples everywhere
and this is a you know a very good
testbed to just like learn it's like the
smallest simplest problem that needs a
hierarchical model but I could find that
that exists in like Bayesian statistics
that's why it's totally so you just sort
of build a model so you get your data
you put together your treatment of facts
you put together your standard error of
the effect estimates you basically
translate this here which is like you're
a specification of your model so theta
is your groupings so of of a of each
school mule and tower like your hyper
parameters over your over your space and
why is the thing that you're trying to
model that's your likelihood function if
you go back to earlier on when we had
like likelihood times prior equals
posterior our assume you know mu and tau
or in some sense a prior over your your
your model because you're assuming
something about like higher scores are
distributed it's worth reading more
there's lots of examples on it
the advantage of the notebook is you get
time to go through these things slowly
but basically you've I've transformed
this from math into PI mc3 syntax so
those are you do not know the pious III
syntax you just basically have a whiff
statement I went into a statement you
just write math so it's you know it's
actually not too difficult to go from
you know an example in the literature to
you know to it like a model so
so kind of the first thing when an
auntie modeling framework you have a
model you're you do an inference you see
how good your model is then you go back
to the start you use your the stuff that
you learned to go back to do a better
model one of the other things I want to
emphasize which is probably a more
general point than just being sophistic
sees you have to be very careful with
your evaluation metrics so my first
evaluation metric is R squared R squared
should be less than one one should be
about one so it's a size or have a
similar to R squared
it's a colleague Alban ravenson
statistic and we see here this is close
to one we see all these that all these
values here are close to one so if we
were naive we would just look at this
and say everything's too grand
everything's fine however if you do more
analysis and look at some of the other
things you'll see here that you know you
seem to see like flatlining here
flatlining in any of these like
Diagnostics the the the metaphor I use
when teaching this is that you should
have a hairy caterpillar on the right
it's not very perfect like notion but it
is intuitive so this is not hairy
caterpillar there is something wrong
with our model so there's a couple of
other metrics you can use we won't worry
too much about these they are worth
looking at yourself if you want to know
more but this is a Bayesian fraction of
missing information and it's like energy
plots the blue and the orange should be
the same there should be no difference
between them if there is a difference
between them particularly in the tails
thus indicates our sampler hasn't
sampled very well so your MCMC sampler
has to explore your space well and has
to mix very well and and the reason that
it won't explore your space well is
either you've made it too short in this
case this is a very short sampler or
your space is complicated has
Kings and curvature and is you know it
gets dropped and local minima so
furthermore not only have some
indication that our model is bad we can
like look at divergences and this is all
kind of like built into it so because I
know what the answer should be for this
I've sort of plotted on the graph this
is like the screen line you'll see that
this there's estimation of love tau
which is one of the observations we're
trying to get doesn't converge so it's
sort of like hasn't hasn't reached it
indicates that there's something wrong
in our model um I talked a bit more
about the geometry of it but you know
you can use these Diagnostics so here
all these green dots are divergences you
know there should all be red
this indicates that somehow it's got
like stuck in some sort of like we call
people call it a formal but you imagine
it geometrically you can imagine like
for example geometrically that you have
some space like this and your your your
sampler sort of gets stuck there and
hasn't explored all this other space
because for your sampler to give you a
good estimate it has to explore all this
space so here is sort of like gob called
in the same way like you have like in
the same way like a gradient descent
algorithm that gets still kind of local
Optima you can use your analogy from
other things so because our divergences
tell us or something wrong we can
explore like doing different models so
in this in the notebooks I I try a
couple of techniques but we're not going
to talk about them you can look at them
yourselves
the important thing is that you read
parametrize sorry okay so in the norm
centered for parameter ization we do not
try to fit the grip level parameters
directly rather we fit a little guys in
variable from which we can recover the
group level parameters the only
difference here is this like theta tooth
here which we applied to our DTM we look
at the Diagnostics we can see here that
our MCMC estimation along tau has
converged so just by like changing the
shape of the model like we're taking the
model light of your local minimum you're
using this Diagnostics and forming a
better model we're able to get something
that's like Eliza's do a rigorous and
inference about this phenomenon
so
okay okay there's not really much more
to say after No
although the summary points I had were
that you always have to diagnose your
model you Bayesian statistics is usable
like it's applicable to small data
problems with domain knowledge and the
libraries are mature you know there are
examples and use cases all around if you
want to learn more you know
probabilistic programming primer com is
a good course I notice I wrote it and
the point if you're if you're not even
thinking about Bayesian statistics is
though is to think of the larger point
of not to just trust one metric
evaluation like too often we hear over
the accuracy is good and we don't talk
about all the ways of looking on the
model we don't look at precision we
don't look at f1 score
we don't look at like are more
complicated metrics any questions that's
me
any question for father any frequentists
in the room your frequent yeah
sorry so one of the questions is why how
does a scale which I'm always asked um
it doesn't scale very well like Bayesian
statistical models have got better and
you know some of the samplers have got
better there are other ways of solving
these of doing Bayesian inference you
can use something called variation
inference which is in most of the modern
libraries the problem of that is that
you get a more biased estimate so you
get speed but you you don't really get
reliability I still an open question
about how well these algorithms work you
know they're very controversial in
modern day statistical circles like
there's something called I in LA which I
don't know anything about but I've heard
you know more promising things about
this unfortunately it's hard to solve
everything and you know small doesn't
necessarily mean that you know you're
you're dealing with like two samples
right small can be hundreds or thousands
or tens of thousands of samples but
perhaps Bayesian statistics doesn't work
well with millions or ten millions of
samples so it's a it's a problem of
yessir loss
oh okay so Theano is being discontinued
by mz3 the core developers are taking
over it until it's like sunset we looked
at a bunch of back ends and ended up
going for tensorflow probability which
is done by Dustin Tran um so he's
basically ported Edward into tensor so
basically Google bottom and he works
there
so now tensor flow probability is very
low level so I've had very little
success like I find it very cumbersome
really and maybe I haven't spent enough
time looking at it we will be like using
it as a back-end I'm currently a lot of
the work being done in PI MC 3 PI M C 4
is to pull out all the plotting
functions so that's like our viz which
is a big project so by pulling out all
these plotting functions you know
they'll probably make the whole moving
to a new back-end easier but I don't
know any dates off the top of my head I
know I was very surprised with how quick
tensor field probability has progressed
so I mean it's like there's been like
they don't have no u-turn stompers
implemented yet they have all their
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo I'm surprised
that their moves aren't so quick so it's
very impressive so it's like Google
seems to be supporting it in some sense
so any other questions
Oh someone's back even like a phone oh
you did
no can't hear you try now I'm guessing
if one was to work through your
notebooks you'd see a series of sort of
divergence graphs and sort of
suggestions of things to try how how bad
is the sort of or even is there any
state aren't me in an artful otherwise
in terms of Auto ml where you know we
even sort of just a reliever you know
two revolting thing to try is the
process automatable at all and and I
don't think so at the moment I don't I
don't know off any coming up or
heuristics for like making better
Bayesian models seems to be a difficult
problem because it seems to be very much
intuitive and you know it and I'm not
aware of any auto and mail can it work
like that at the moment we're still at
the stage that we can like tell you that
your model is bad like and we weren't at
that stage a few years ago there's been
a lot of work on just telling people
that their model is bad and you know
therefore you should yeah so one step at
a time you know we can like maybe
someone can come up with an all-time al
solution but I very early type it any
any other questions with lightning talks
died right stinker bother one more time
[Applause]